hello hello hello people hello the world
hello Cowboys Nation welcome back this
is week three on the edge with your boy
Michael Parson's linebacker for the
Dallas
Cowboys and I just want to say we might
as well get straight into it the reason
why y'all came in here today cows Nation
do not panic um yes it was a rough one
yes there's lots of regrets things that
a bunch of guys wish they could take
back but can we say every day climbing
the mountains going be sunshine and
rainbow rainbows no we got hit by the
storm uh some of my biggest takeaways of
this game was the simple fact of like we
just didn't execute on both sides of the
ball um you can't even say it was the
offense you can't even say it was the
defense give it up 28 points is just
unacceptable regardless of what Dak done
uh the standard we've been playing how
we've been playing just wasn't
acceptable this week and I take
ownership in that you know um it it
hurts because is when you when you go
out there and you practice something and
you you consistently do it and you're
not executing to the way like we were
just beating ourselves uh I don't
necessarily think the Cardinals were a
better team than us at all I think we
have more Talent more skill things like
that but uh I just think we beat
ourselves we weren't playing to our
standard we weren't doing what we were
doing and uh we just got to be better
and the defensive side I gotta make sure
we're better bring that energy um
another takeaway is just that
you know obviously we didn't do what we
were supposed to do in the Red Zone
obviously that's been a big thing people
own that um it is what it is but guess
what it gives us a chance to get better
that's the bright side about this part
um we know what we did it's a chance to
get better um eliminate these things so
it doesn't happen again and allow both
sides to get better and work off each
other so do not panic it's early in the
season it's September I never heard of a
Super Bowl One in September I never want
heard of a Super Bowl being W in October
November or December that thing is one
in February and obviously playing your
uh butt off in January so do not panic
we are going to be okay um and I know a
lot of guys and a lot of people want to
hear about losing Trayvon uh when I
first heard about it um and seen him go
down uh my heart broke bro uh you
talking about someone who's like took me
under the wing um man and just like I
man I just went off to the side to take
a moment from practice and I just like I
really shed tears like you know
trayvon's like really like my family
like he's someone like I know we're
gonna look after each other take care of
each other um and I don't think people
realize how much stuff that we actually
do together so and the energy that he
brings to the team so losing him may
could have been a part just because the
enjoyment and the fun that he brings to
the guys that type of energy is rare and
we're truly going to miss him um like
for example we make sure we bring each
other food to the plane we make sure you
know we always walk out the tunnel
together we always hang out the night
before the game text talk FaceTime go
over stuff just like it's just truly go
it's truly a bummer losing someone like
that and someone that's close and uh at
this point you know he even te we saw
each other right after the game you know
he called me said uh come see me and uh
you know and we just talked a little bit
more he's like man gota y' got to hit it
on so you know this week is all going to
be motivation for my dog Trey um we
going to miss you brother and we're
going to see you soon um but the whole
team felt your absence and we felt that
um and I that's why I thought it was
cool that uh Stefan made you know the
big uh you know he dedicated that game
towards his brother and uh I think we're
gonna do something like that as our team
and our defense um the dedicated game
towards Trey to um because that's our
brother and uh it's not the same without
him out there there so we miss you
brother and we love you and uh we know
what you going to bring next year uh to
help us do it all over again brother um
and even coach McCarthy said it it was a
sunra punch uh to the gut you know
losing a guy like that like um people
who questions trade character and who he
is don't really know him um what he
brings to the team is just
undeniably uh gifted and I mean just the
turnovers he brings the excitement The
Joy like you just can't coach and uh you
know coach Al Harris you know he shed
some cheers too you know uh so I think I
think you guys are getting the grasp of
what it means and what it means to have
him on this
team um and then you know we might as
well keep going getting straight to it I
want to take some questions from the
chat uh you know I know you guys have
some questions about what happened
Sunday so you know I want to hear from
you
guys is it going to take time to adapt
without seven um I think think last week
was our ad uh adaption game you know I
think we all seen what it's like not to
have him out there um I think we all
notice uh what's going on and what we
need to do and how we need to adjust so
I think this week will be much better uh
and all around the
board uh what do I think of what B Scott
said um honestly it hurt me and I I just
think it's too early um without a doubt
it is a big blow to Dallas defense to
lose Trayvon Diggs the like I said the
the typee of guy he he is and what he
brings to our team is just you just Rec
can't recreate that uh and you can't
bring no one in to replace him um so
when you and as a former player I just
don't believe that you should put that
type of luck or say the type of things
you do after someone makes a significant
injury especially like ACL it's not like
Trayvon was out for four to six weeks or
he had to be on Place IR because of
hamstring um you know
uh ACL is a season ending injury you
know so I just don't agree with that um
but every man is different you know if
you're going to change for the cameras
and things like that uh then that's just
who you are but as a player and you know
for where I'm going and you know
obviously doing this I would never
intentionally talk bad or uh wish a
injury and say think that's like a joke
on anyone uh I never uh had a
significant injury like that but um
talking to guys and seeing people go do
it uh it's just not something to joke
about um and let's just continue on uh
and we're going to start off with my dog
of the week and my dog of the week has
to go out to my dog miles Garrett um I
know people saw me imitating him last
week over to Center uh miles Garrett is
truly Just One of a Kind um I don't
think there's anyone in the league like
him and I mean the fact that he has
people following him like I honestly I
like as soon as I saw I sent to my coach
like we got to adapt to this like miles
Garrett is like I just don't think if
you look at the type of attention uh
that he brings um besides me miles
Garrett and uh a coup a few other guys
like Crosby I don't think anyone's
bringing that type of attention uh
towards their for their team um a lot of
guys are getting single blocked and
things like that but miles Garrett finds
a way had three and a half sacks that me
as a dog he tackled The Tackle and the
QB on one play I mean the guy's just
freaky uh I watch the guy all the time
uh talking about a guy who I watch his
film and see what he does and what he
goes through and how he gets moved
around um truly aspiring bro and I don't
think I think everyone should take
notice to what miles gar is doing um and
right now I think between uh me TJ miles
and a few other guys I mean this race is
really up for anyone uh this is really
going down to the wire everyone's
bringing out their best stuff and I
can't cons continue I can't wait to
continue to see what the rest of the
year looks like and then it it continues
on to what I told you guys the Browns
are the real deal uh the Browns have a
top defense in the League last year I
mean uh talent-wise last year and now
they're showing with talent and
discipline we could be really good um if
you look at how they lost last week uh
their uh uh their uh their Browns
offense uh gave up more points than the
Browns defense so let's look at here the
Browns could be a three and0 team um and
they they're on a hot streak Deshawn
Watson is playing up to the standard now
you know he did not fall off uh people
forget this man was suspended for almost
he didn't play football for almost two
years two years guys and then when he
came back it was just like oh we're out
of playoffs so we're just they're not
they're just now getting a flow of
things uh I'm super excited to see how
this thing goes uh but Deshawn Watson is
the real deal the Cleveland Browns is
the real deal and I don't think we
should be surprised about this anymore
um the Browns are here I think that we
might see them uh potentially win a
division it's G to be a close one but uh
I don't really see a lot of people doing
anything with their defense I think
they're putting all together that DC
they br in is doing what he has to do
and uh we all need to take notice I
think you know it's really gonna come
down to in their division uh Browns and
Bengals and you know uh depending on how
Joe burrow comes back from this calf
injury it's going to be really exciting
to see so I think everyone should buckle
up and get ready for that division
matchup uh when they see each other
later on the season because I think
that's GNA be the that might be the
reason if you know the Browns could be a
higher seed in the thing uh in playoffs
or not because the Browns are definitely
a playoff team and we need to be ready
for
that um another player that caught that
has caught my eye on the edge is the
Rams uh wide receiver number 17 NOA uh
man is he lighting the league on fire as
a rookie wide receiver coming in uh no
one having no expectations I think he's
blown the expectations off the ceiling
for everyone I think it's going to be
even more exciting seeing him back with
Cooper cup when he gets back so having
that two matchup having two guys that
matth Matthew Stafford likes to throw to
I think everyone knows he likes to go to
Cooper cup especially when he's in a
lineup but now having a hidden gym
saying hey I can trust this guy I can
depend on this guy I know he's going to
make the catch I know he's going to do
what he has to do uh I think the Rams
have the potential to be very scary and
make that run uh like Shawn McVey always
does and you know change the way that
this team's looking at um this is a real
serious team I I think everyone uh saw
the Rams last year and said well we can
write them off but Shawn McVey say hold
on wait a minute I'm not done and uh I
think we really seeing it he drafted
well got this guy he's goingon to get
his Guy Cooper cut back soon so I think
we should be very excited about the Rams
and see what they do this year I think
they might upset uh a couple teams this
year and see how they place in the
division it's going to be good
especially with the Seahawks and the
49ers so it's going to be very good to
see um I think something we also need to
talk about on the edge right now is the
Broncos uh what's going on in Denver uh
Denver had a top rated defense last year
think just gave up 70 um what are they
missing what is going on what is the
missing piece down in Denver um we all
put a lot of uh we put a lot of Praise
on Shawn Payton to turn the system
around especially trading to get Russell
Wilson we thought these guys would
instant be a high playoff team and maybe
even a Super Bowl team but it's not
looking like that right now and that's
causing for suspicion um you know and
you also would think it would take a
jump after last year uh knowing what
they have done uh and where they was at
last year and it's kind of it's starting
to become I think detrimental to the
team um if we go to what Garrett B said
about the team um it it's kind of
questioning uh he's like when you one of
your you know especially one of your
veteran players degrade the team and say
man I'm tired of losing what does that
mean for the team now what are the
emotions like going through your head
personally
it's uh tired of losing man uh I've been
here for seven years and all I've done
is lost and it's
frustrating now that that's pain and I
uh I think people need to realize
something when you compete at the
highest level and you you're putting in
work and it's constantly hope hope
they're like oh we got Russ this is hope
all we got Shawn Payton is Hope and it's
just not getting to where you want it to
be that hurts guys and I don't think
people realizing that and instead of
that sometimes you want to take the
positive way out yes this loss hurt but
we need guys in the Broncos room I know
pator Chain's a guy and I know he's a
young guy but even me I'm trying to lean
towards that hey we need to pick this up
hey I know how who we can be and how we
can be it and we need to show that every
week so there has to be a guy over there
that's going to step up and say hey we
got to change this around and it and it
can't always be Russell Wilson you know
everyone always thinks that QB has to be
the leader sometimes it giv be guy that
everyone knows going to practice his
butt off work his butt off and things
like that because that's things that
people need and they just need to help
turning around um obviously losing 70 to
20 um 0 and three uh that most poorts
scored games since
1966 like come on guys like y'all Gotta
Get It Together someone has to Signal it
hey Pat I'm challenging you I know you
that dog up there get these boys
together brother I know you can do it um
and then I want to say you know two said
that they didn't go for 73 because they
don't want to humiliate teams I mean
after 70 points you don't think this is
already humiliating you might as well go
for the record but I understand what
you're trying to say is you don't want
to I don't know I guess get
disrespectful um but listen we get it uh
I think either way 70 to you know 20 we
already said what the hell like what the
hell just happened down in Miami once
again uh this AFC team of Miami is
looking serious and um Tua is healthy I
think we all said this offseason if Tua
can stay healthy the sky's the limit for
this Miami team and everything's ping
out to be true and we need to take
notice and we need to start preparing to
see what these guys down in Miami are
doing because they're consistently
averaging 30 with two in the lineup 30
or more so I think that we need to pay
attention and start to lock in on these
guys because Miami is the real deal and
they might be the number one team in the
AFC and I know I know I know I know uh
people gonna say that cheats but we'll
get into that in a second I just want to
take a second on my guy Tyreek Hill
saying he's the lion and he said he got
something for me coming off the edge
hold on wait a minute Tyreek wait a
minute Tyreek I'm letting you know
there's a big difference between me and
those other guys that you coming off the
edge with I listen Tyreek if you come
over my and I see you coming my way I'm
sending you to the tent I'm sending you
to the sideline you going to say hey
coach I don't want nothing to do with
Michael Parsons you don't want to do
that hey I already said it once and I
said on social media my baby girl is
getting cheetah print for for Christmas
she's getting cheetah print come over
here to my site my baby girl is getting
cheetah print but all love my guy what
you doing right now you really showing
that you let's argue about it if you're
wide receiver one it's Tyreek Hill wide
receiver one I mean we see what he's
doing we see what Justin Jefferson's
doing um who who's wide receiver one how
are you going to argue it these guys are
lighting the league up right now but the
difference is the Dolphins are three and
0 the Vikings are 0 and
three you
know who's going to argue it right now
right now we have to give it toq Hill he
has to be the best wide receiver uh in
the league because he's making the most
impact um so let me get back into and
then before I get to that I want to say
how we Stack Up Against against the
Dolphins honestly it's going to be a
hell of a matchup on Christmas Day I
can't honestly I can't wait uh to to you
know go through it with these guys it's
gonna be a war day um and it's gonna be
very exciting uh obviously I think the
Dolphins have the most
explosive and I explosive I say speed uh
in a NFL I mean I don't know where you
stack it against the Bengals who has the
best uh group between between the
Bengals and the Dolphins but wide
receiver and core they have both of the
best teams however you want to argue if
you want speed or you want guys to go up
in MOS because that's what Jamar Chase
and T Higgins do I mean they just gonna
go get it so however you want to argue
it I think those guys are the best uh
and it's not even arguing and now it
just brings me to my point of who's our
top four AFC teams um let and and let's
be honest about this uh what the
Dolphins have done is they took a top
five defense from last year and just
dropped 70 um they they dropped 30 30
plus points on the Chargers who we all
come in to the season say hey everyone's
healthy got Jason Jackson back they got
khil Mack back they got Derwin James
they got Joey Bosa they got Kenneth
Murray they got a Sant s you like hey
this team has the potential to being a
top defense and they go out there and
dropped 30 plus okay so we're not
sleeping on the Dolphins we know who
they are they didn't sleep on no one and
they've been lighting the league up so
right now my number one team in the AFC
is the Dolphins
okay now we can't go away from our Super
Bowl champs okay uh what they they just
dropped 40 plus on the Bears and we're
gonna get into that a little bit but I
think they're back you know having
Kelsey back in the lineup and having
Chris Jones who I told y'all would be a
factor if you didn't think Chris Jones
would have made an impact in that Lions
game you guys are crazy Chris Jones is
just that guy uh and you just can't take
away defense I think he would have made
a plays the way he's been making plays
since he's been back so my number two
team right now has to be the Chiefs um
three we got to go with Cleveland um
Cleveland's defense just wins
championships I mean defense always wins
championships I don't care what no one
says um you know Chiefs defense at the
end of the day they got that stop on
Herz and they won that game so defense
always wins championships so I'm going
to go with the Cleveland Browns if
Deshawn Watson could keep clicking and
that defense could keep clicking we're
seeing a great Cleveland Brown Brown
team number four is tough okay um it it
it's many places you can go with this
but we got to go with the Buffalo Bills
I you just can write off Josh Allen Josh
Allen is a guy Josh Allen's in the
Buffalo Bills they have extreme amount
of Talent Matt Milano uh Porter uh porer
on that defense Ed Oliver I mean and
they still haven't got Von Miller back
and I think a lot of people are
forgetting about Von Miller Von Miller
is a all decade defensive end one of the
greatest defensive EV to ever play this
football game uh Hall of Famer we can't
wait to see V get back on field I don't
think enough people were talking about
the bills still don't have Von Miller
back so we gotta go with the Buffalo
Bills at four and I think the whole AFC
playoff birth is gonna come down is
gonna come down to the wire it's gonna
be super exciting and uh I can't wait to
watch
it uh let's let's bring it back to a
team where we all thought was going to
make Super Bowl
hopes H and is it it's hard to even talk
about this because Aaron Rogers injury
and who Aaron Rogers is and what it
could have meant for the Jets with Aaron
roggers and let me tell you why they
should and I know and we look on the
sideline we see the frustration all the
players and especially with Garrett
Wilson with Zach Wilson and it it gets a
little toxic sometimes you know um when
you got this between your best wide
receiver and your starting quarterback
it hurt and we see it on I think
everyone s we saw it between Jaylen Herz
and AJ Brown uh should we should we over
Panic no but we got understand uh
there's a lot of emotions that come with
football when you're competing and you
want to be the best and you know you're
unguardable Gary Wilson is one of them
guys who we can't sleep on he's a top 10
top 15 receiver um and he's a our you
know offensive rookie of the year so you
know when he's not getting a receptions
and he's getting held to certain amount
of yards there's a lot of frustration
and and as deserves and I say we can't
panic because look and I'mma and and
this is the truth okay all offseason
everyone's been talking about Aaron
Rodgers okay uh you know coach Salah uh
you know is a great coach but guess what
he's been playing in the half Aon Rogers
that team was getting built for Aaron
Rodgers that team wasn't getting built
for Zack Wilson Zack Wilson yes he was
in training camp but no one was
expecting him to play he probably wasn't
taking the same reps getting the same
looks getting everything like Aaron
Rogers was and that's just the reality
and now they're trying to adjust and
limit the system and come back to a new
system because of Zack Wilson and his
inability is not and he being compared
to Hall of Famer which isn't fair he had
he needs time to grow he needs time to
learn um y'all are forgetting that
there's only 32 starting jobs in the NFL
quarterback and he's one of them right
now if it was so easy a bunch of people
could be quarterback and I know there's
a lot of frustration for jets fans and
things like that but this isn't a walk
in the park job there's only 32 starting
jobs in the NFL for a reason at
defensive ends you can be rotatable
there's two of them on East Side Corners
there's more quarterback is one of the
hardest positions in the NFL and you
expect a third year guy who got benched
last year say hey we're going to take
Aaron roders his Focus might have been
there we don't know what his Focus his
mentor was like when the whole trade
thing was happening how the guys treated
him and a lot goes into it on how much
you want to give to this team his team
needs to give back to him they need to
pour into him so he could be the guy
they want to be and if they can do that
um there's a bunch of free agent guys um
we saw earlier Matt Ryan said he
wouldn't take the job um but you can say
Cam Newton and Joe flacko we we truly
just don't know I just don't think
there's a a guy right now that we can
say that could come in and just change
the whole system around and say hey this
guy is gonna take us to the Super Bowl I
I I don't think there is a guy out there
right now unless you trade for him and
he's a backup somewhere else um that's
going to make that impact and get you
what you want uh just Nation so pour
into him uh help groom him grow him and
things like that but I think
everything's going to be okay once you
get back into
it um I see a lot of people are talking
about the lost to the Steelers Josh
mcdel decid to kick on Fourth and eight
in the Red Zone when they were down
eight I think we saw something very
similar to the situation with the
Packers in the Bucks in the NFC
championship game uh with Rogers uh very
skeptical um by then the day I he played
it like hey either way we gotta score to
win the game but I think in that
situation uh I just because it's Fourth
and eight I don't think people realize
at Fourth and eight it's a wide range of
what the defense could come in they can
send out an allout Blitz they could you
know it's easy and I don't think people
realize how hard it is to get eight
yards in the NFL uh it it's extremely
hard that's why there's a bunch of three
and outs there's a like it's like let's
be real guys like it I know it's
frustrating in that position I guess you
really could go either way you know if
he's going to sense like hey either way
we gota go down here and win the game or
we going either way they needed to get a
stop um and they just didn't do it so at
the day you can really go either way on
it um if it's me and if I'm playing you
know whatever in that situation uh I
think it gives a different type of
belief in your team when you do go for
it say hey I do believe in you I think
we could get this so let's get it um and
that that brings a different type of
Faith like hey like you know you fired
up like and the defense is rallying you
up the offense is like hey let's do this
like like let's lock in let's do what we
have to do um so it would have been more
exciting to see it but I guess we can
get why he did that um and we also have
a clip of what Devonte Adams said after
the
game I don't act like it's all crazy you
know it's week three but I don't got
time to wait around you know and it's
not a personal thing I mean it is a
personal thing but it ain't just about
me but I mean it's not my mentality to
sit here and try to take all season to
figure it out use these early games like
this to establish identity and we uh we
not doing things the right way to to
establish a winning culture um early in
the season so we got to do something to
turn that around doing something about
it so that when we go out there the next
time it looks different it's not
supposed to just be a week of just
talking about we got to go out
there and do it and you know that's
that's the that's the theme of this year
is doing it not just talking about it
and figuring out what we need to do we
did all that last year this year we got
to be about it mhm okay he said I don't
got time to just wait around it's not my
mentality Take It All season and figure
it out
okay let's realize where Devonte Adams
came from he came from Green Bay who's a
winning culture who had a great comeback
win Jordan love Congratulations by the
way um and beat a great defensive Saints
team and that was a tremendous comeback
uh and his quarterback was Aaron Rogers
and the Cure they have built he knows
what it looks like he's been a multiple
NFC championship games um he's played uh
in big-time games and he's pretty much
dominated since you know uh been on
winning team since he been here so he
knows the C he knows what it looks like
he knows what it should look like and
when it's not up to the expectation yes
he has a right to be upset um when
you're trying to change a losing culture
to a winning
culture uh it's challenging because you
got to get these guys to see what you
see and you know the experiences of what
you went through he's looking from a
different scope um and what it could
mean is and what he's trying to say is
he hey yes I'm one of the highest paid
guys I am one of the best receivers but
I want to win I came here because I
wanted to win you know he didn't come
there he came there for Derek Carl if we
want to be real uh when that whole trade
thing happened and obviously losing his
guy they bring in um another quarterback
but we have to be real like he is in a
winning culture he wants to build a
winning culture he knows what he should
look like and I and I don't disagree
with him when someone is not playing up
to the standard it's not okay and I said
all guy sometimes guys just want to
collect checks and some guys actually
playing because it means something and
he's a player you tell when it means
something to some people okay when I
play I want to play because it means
something to me and I want people to
know that and I think that's why people
uh they love me and they see it because
they see the rage the passion that come
with the game and you see it from guys
like Devonte Adams you see it from guys
like Patrick Mahomes Travis Kelce you
see the passion that they want to bring
they want to win they're eager to win so
no I'm not mad at it uh he deserves that
winning culture he's come from one he
knows it's look like so people should
listen to him um don't take this as
offense I don't think think Devonte ad
is going nowhere I don't think the
Raiders are gonna let him go nowhere but
he's saying like hey guys like we need
to tap in I think obviously you see the
difference between him and Garrett BS a
guy that's like man I feel like you know
I I'm tired of losing no we needed to
get together we need to be positive like
it shouldn't look like this we shouldn't
keep making the same mistakes and that's
what I'm talking about the growth of
between a good identity good culture
versus a bad culture and losing
culture but you know on to some positive
stuff I think the biggest news of the
week is Travis Kelce and Taylor
Swift like when I heard when I
originally heard about that I said man
he shot from Deep he shot from Deep now
T Kel is my boy and I done saw him out a
couple times and that boy's a dog he's a
he's a dog but shooting at T Swift like
who's a Swifty
like like all my like hold on quick
timeline Travis had his podcast when he
went into a concert and tried to give
her his phone number and it didn't go
right right rors came out they were
hanging out Travis with on maffy dropped
a line about
Arrowhead and then we see our Arrowhead
yo okay hold on now this is this is
where things get like suspenseful
like hold on tra hold on like like like
when I saw that I couldn't believe it
like when I saw that video of uh your
mom and T Swift I almost lost my mind
for you like T like like she sing to you
at night bro like I would think if I had
a bad day I'd be like sing to me Taylor
sing to me like put something into my
ear like hey you belong with me yes I am
a Swifty I'm back in the 20 I'm the old
Swift though like I want the old Swift
you
know uh you know when she was out there
saying
like she wears t-shirts you know she
wear short skirts and I wear t-shirts
big hype for you dog you know what it is
dog I mean damn you shot from deep and
you scor you Stephen Curry my brother
you might be the new step of football
that's dope I can't even lie I think I
want to see someone shoot at somebody
else the NFL we up right now City Boys
is up hey I challenge all my other NFL
guys start shooting from Deep shooting
from Deep let's see if someone can get
somebody like I don't
know oh I gotta think about this we got
to start shooting brother I shooting you
know Zena shoot at Zenda something we
got to start going Brothers uh I think
tra set the standard for this uh what
are my thoughts about it I think it's
dope you know and I think love is
important uh you know I I think it's
always good to find love uh no matter
where you find it how you find it I
think they're gonna have a dope Love
Story one day I think this is a great uh
couple um and you know it it makes me
think about how many how many people
might have came to a Cowboys game have
people ever like I mean I don't think I
would be nervous if Taylor Swift was in
like the Cowboy stadium cheering me on
like I honestly I I probably like maybe
have like two sacks or something like oh
sh Taylor's here like oh two sacks like
I might like I would probably growl at
like like oh Taylor he's he's a dominant
he's a lion like I don't know like I
would have to go kind of crazy I
wouldn't be nervous like I like T Swift
here like I remember like George Lopez
came and like George Lopez was like
super dope because I was like yo I used
to watch like the Lopez Show like George
Lopez Show I was like dang like I was
super hype about that so you know I
don't know I guess like I never been
nervous I guess it makes me more excited
like when like people you known growing
up and you seen growing up like you know
I don't know that that's just me I am a
Swifty uh my favorite song is you belong
with me uh she crushed it um what's
Travis intentional about inv her to the
Bears game I think we all had the uh the
Chiefs winning did he just want to see a
win or you know honestly the Chiefs is
good for any week but uh I think there's
a little suspicion about that um you
know but outside of Taylor Swift and the
that whole incident the Bears had a week
um people can expect the Bears to go out
and beat the Chiefs after after
equipment has been stolen I mean their
DC decides to resign a whole bunch of
allegations getting put out we don't
know what's going on I
mean man what's going on over there and
what I hate is that everyone's putting
on Justin there's so many distractions
between the play call and defense I mean
at the end of the day you can't win a
game after your defense gives up 4
something points regardless of how
Justin field just playing they can't get
a stop they're eating up clock so that
means Justin has to drop back you can't
open up the Playbook I mean we just have
to be a little bit
realistic did we expect Justin fields to
turn around his program in three years a
program that hasn't been at the at its
prime in so long gave away all pro Ron
Smith uh BR in Tain Evans instead of
your allpro guy I mean you gave away
Robert Quinn I mean you try to draft
guys but it's the NFL it takes guys a
while to add on my guy brisker over
there is hooping you still got Eddie
Jackson but you know it don't I don't
think two or three guys can change a
defense it takes all 11 I don't think
people are realizing that it takes all
11 on offense
too but the good news is the Bears have
draft Capital they could keep building
onto this roster uh they still got the
Panthers pick and the Panthers aren't
looking too sound right now so they
might have an early pick next year and
they might be able to get a guy like
Marvin Harrison to add to DJ Moore which
be exciting get you another old lineman
um so we just gotta give a time and give
a hope uh just give him the same Grace
you know Tua went had a first couple
rough years um there's a couple other
guys that had a rough at first let's
just let's like and then two didn't
change until he had Tyreek Hill like
let's be real you know DJ Moore is a
good receiver but would you say he's a
Class A guy would you put him up there
with Tyreek Hill does he have the
potential yes DJ Moore is a hell of a
player he's a dog regardless like I'm
not saying anything bad about DJ Moore
but Tyreek Hill didn't make a huge jump
I mean uh two didn't make a huge jump
until he got Tyreek Hill uh let's put
another guy Josh Allen didn't make a
huge jump and until got Stefon dicks so
let's give everyone that same courtesy
that same action let a team build up the
builds were always a premium team let
them build up give them a chance don't
give up bears Nation like it takes time
it takes time and then you'll see the
significance in it do not rush this type
of process when you rush it and we give
up on guys we see guys don't come out
the same let them get confidence let
them get going but that's what I gotta
say about the Bears game uh you guys
liked when I talk college balls last
week so shout out to the so shout out to
my guys um and first you know I got to
start off with Penn State and let's
start off with a we are we are we are
y'all know it is Big shout out gave up
only 76 offensive yards that defense is
booming y'all know where we get it from
there's nothing like a white you can't
come into a white out I think it's gonna
be sweet I think Iowa came out there and
they just thought it was gonna be sweet
and we came out there firing that white
out there's nothing like it in the world
I don't think people realize how great
that white out is it's special just look
at that environment and my guys did what
they had to do and crushed Iowa uh a big
10 matchup we might be underrated after
we seeing uh Ohio State struggle against
Notre Dame and find out Notre Dame only
had 10 players on the last play of the
game I don't know how that happens but
that's the reality Notre Dame only had
10 players on the last play of the game
and they ran to the Gap that was open
and the guy was missing so that hurts I
mean that truly hurts um and it hurts
that we saw Marvin Harrison go out can
that affect that Ohio State team not
having Marvin Harris out there we don't
know the extent of that injury um so
it's something to keep an eye on but
Penn State is on the rise baby pen State
on the rise and I want to say something
jar you keep going baby I'm loving what
I'm saying oh we are baby I'm so excited
we might have a real chance I think we
do have a chance to go all the way Big
10 championship game college football
playoff uh this team reminds me a lot of
when I was in college uh my sophomore
year when we were top
uh five team number four in the country
before we went down and uh lost to
Minnesota I mean we was booming Abdul
Carter Curtis Jacobs you got chop
Robinson on defense oh man man that
front Adisa Isaac is looking monstrous
guys Penn State we are coming baby um
the Heisman race is heating up the
Heisman race is heating up Caleb
Williams and Michael penck Jr out of
Washington man oh man can Caleb Williams
repeat Heisman when's the last time
that's been done I mean the way he's
been playing and the style that he's
been playing can we honestly argue has
he
been is he gonna be the oh I and I hate
throwing out these things because you
know it I think we did that with Victor
but he might be the best QB we've seen
in recent drafts in a long time he might
be the best recruit that's come is going
to come out this draft and question is
should he he's striving at UFC the nil I
know is booming for him uh and he
doesn't have to deal with another drama
um are we gonna see him come out I we
don't know but this is Boom heating up
serious Caleb will Caleb Williams and
Michael penck Jr is hooping we see you
Brothers I mean keep going I'm excited
to see how it looks like I want to see
what USC does to Colorado I think that's
going to be the game how do Colorado
bounce back from that loss against
Oregon and the only way that happens is
you got to learn fix the mistakes um
Oregon trolled uh Colorado I thought
they were being like little girls to be
honest with you um I don't agree with
that coach did before
pregame uh listen one thing about
football it's never about them like when
a coach that just brings a toxic
environment like it's never about what
the next man is doing it's never about
what the next coach is doing how they're
building their team the grass is green
on your side you don't know what it's
like on the other side so don't talk
about the other side I never agree with
things like that I do I just don't agree
with that you need to focus inhouse keep
all your stuff in house um so I just
didn't agree how Oregon was treating
Colorado how they were spitting on them
spitting on the name uh but at the end
of the day like we see in
everything in football it's always like
you got served today you know everyone
has his day and uh Oregon had their day
against Colorado uh obviously Colorado
couldn't stop the run they had their day
so we got to see them bounce back Lear
learn it just to stop that run um and
Coach Prime said this is the worst
you're gonna see us um and you know and
it's going to be exciting to see so uh
uh and we going to take some questions
from the chat right now um we're going
to go back to the chat real quick quick
uh in the chat said are the Cardinals a
sleeper team in the NFC um I think maybe
so um you know they have a lot of talent
over there they still got Rond Del Moore
a healthy Rond Del Moore um they still
got Mars Brown a healthy Mars Brown the
question is how good would they be when
Kyler Murray comes back if Kyler Murray
could come back and continue to play Pro
Bowl all pro football uh they might be a
sleeper and you know there are growing
program uh you know I think
that they have done a lot of good things
and they've shown a lot of good team
like I said they've shown a lot of fight
okay they almost beat the commanders
they came back they almost beat the
Giants they came back and they obviously
came out strong against us and we didn't
come back so this team has a chance to
be a three and 0 team I don't think they
should be slept on uh I think this is a
a this is a good team um so they really
are a sleeper if kber could come back
and play great football
uh you know I think the cars had a
chance to come in and sneak in uh sneak
into that highly stacked uh Rams and SE
Seattle division who we're all talking
about right now with the 49ers um so
it'll be intense to see how they do next
week against that matchup uh and it's
something that we all gotta keep our
eyes out on uh and another question we
got is how do we feel about playing Zeke
next week obviously Zeke's my guy um you
know we miss Zeke at where we at in
Dallas uh Zeke has always been great to
Dallas uh he's a legend in Dallas um so
it's going to be very fun you know Zeke
always used to play around with me in
practice and you know uh I just know he
might be coming for me but I can't wait
to see Zeke uh see how he doing and
obviously get that Holly uh talented
matchup uh versus him so very excited uh
and I can't wait for it but uh super
matchup is that we got we got Monday
night matchup I'm looking forward to
Eagles versus bucks and now the question
is now with the Vikings going 0 and
three uh it's hard to solidify you know
people are questioning Baker um and you
know and they're off to a pretty good
start but people are questioning and I
think this is a great uh place and a
great team for Baker to face then say uh
hush hush up the critics I mean he's
going against this talented Eagles
defense how can he look how would he do
uh when adversity Heights uh hits in
that game because adversity will always
hit in a game especially when you going
against a talented team like the eagles
how will he overcome it how can he lead
that team to a win it's going to be very
exciting uh I can't wait to see it will
Baker H the Eagles their first loss who
knows it's gonna be exciting to see I
know I can't wait to watch it it's a
possibility if Baker could come out Fir
and get Mike Evans going get Chris
Godwin going get that highly T to
offense going and get some stops on
defense they might have a chance but can
jayen Herz and AJ Brown Devonte Smith
smother them and do what they do best
it's going to be a good one uh and we
can't wait to watch it but before I go I
always like to give you guys a preview
uh you know a week ahead and I'm gonna
go ahead and do one more question before
I go is how is Mazy Smith come along is
he going to be a good piece soon I think
mazy's come along great I think he's
learning he's adapting he's starting to
get comfortable I think he's a guy
that's going to keep coming along and I
think towards late in season midseason
and when we get in mid-season form we
got a chance to see Mazi be very
dominant take over the league take over
this interior job and uh show why he was
the highly talented pick in our first
round pick so super excited for him and
I can't wait to see
that before we go I just want to say how
are we prepping after this week and you
know that tough loss um you know it's
gonna be very exciting uh and it's going
to be a chance for us to get a
Redemption we know how the Patriots
gonna come at with them having Zeke and
we know they like to run the ball and
bich che's creativity so it's going to
be very fun for us to get our Redemption
um show that we could get back on top uh
after adversity hits and it's gonna be
very exciting facing Zeke I never fa
Zeke um he always talked about how it
would feel if I ever tackled him and how
he comes um so it's going to be very
very very very interesting um and if
you're not in the stadium this might be
the greatest setup to watch the game my
guy he was suited up I thought he was
getting ready to take my job tune in to
my guy right now his setup is off the
chain man look at him paron Jersey on
pants on I mean I thought we were
switching places I honestly did I mean
there's no better place I mean this is a
true Cowboys fan I mean we got to do
something special for this guy I think
this guy should reach out to me so I can
show him the love that he gives Cowboys
Nation because that's what it's all
about and the jerseys I got up this week
I got my man Devonte Adams because I
understand his frustration his passion
for greatness obviously the cheatah I
wanted to show you some love because you
are hooping my boy can't wait for that
matchup and stop running from me and
Madden my guy don't run from me no more
I want to play you now don't run for me
and my guy Jo oide baby from the Bengals
uh three teams one team that's you know
at the top of the uh you know they at
top of the mountain right now that's
Miami Dolphins and two teams who's
trying to find their way so my guy
Devonte Adams good luck um and Joseph
oai good luck baby I'll see y'all soon
and that's a wrap on the edge I
appreciate y'all for tuning in tune in
next week for more action more talk and
more hottest takes in the league right
now let's get it appreciate
y'all
sh